kathleen kennedy and kiri heart well
joining our Star Wars filmmaking
community is a rising star whose work on
monsters and the blockbuster success of
Godzilla's drawn the attention of the
world and his next film will be the
first Star Wars anthology film so please
welcome mr. Gareth Edwards
I can shed some light on it with our
first official summary of this movie so
bloggers taking out a rogue band of
resistance fighters unite for a daring
mission to steal the Death Star plans
and bring new hope to the galaxy it was
really George's idea in fact one of the
first things he sat down and talked to
me about was not only picking up the
saga again which he never envisioned he
would do but was ready to do but he also
was really interested in exploring all
the stories that might exist inside the
universe we're going to be calling them
anthology films and that is sort of i
think a really exciting idea now it
sounds from the description really that
this is it this is an ensemble picture
when we're talking about you know group
military activity but we've only we've
only introduced one of the cast so far
and that's Felicity Jones okay can you
talk about what what drew your attention
to her Felicity's amazing is the
simplest way to say it she's fantastic
and but she plays I think I can say this
a rebel soldier you just said it
we've talked about zero dark thirty
Saving Private Ryan rut Saving Private
Ryan Black Hawk Down you're not kidding
about this being a war picture are you
know it's cold Star Wars
you
you